[Music]
I'm starving so what do you want to eat
go in a burrito with brown rice grilled
vegetables the freitas salsa and walk on
a whole-wheat tortilla and avocado water
yeah I was black and gray man in Sevilla
I got a condo women baby yo us you know
has invited oh god I get the cabbage
crackle pop song pop us on me turn
around in Java throw up and just drop
opponents out a Miami any white dope
window Danny don't start out with dinner
who y'all got that baby I got it if you
want princess party you've gotta get you
more sorry that's me welcome I like
thank you good luck to that beep hi my
name is Amanda I'm going to be your
masseuse for today
nice to meetcha what do you like like a
Swedish massage or deep tissue ever
works
my back is kind of a mess you can sort
of get in there and it's my favorite go
ah ah you know that's me
did you get a tattoo of your son oh
that's me you got that a really long
time ago so what do you do for fun just
kind of relax silently hey no idea just
finish guy 1 got up walked away yeah
scrutinize it just can't stand that like
you so much for them and they just so
appreciate anything
[Applause]
how's that
[Music]
by the way that's gonna be $200 see I'm
so excited shame Azoff awesome ready
good right I usually sing like a high C
okay put me in a high C sure
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey